[Музика]
Привіт усім і ласкаво просимо на
урок англійської,
мене звуть Ілана, і я запрошую вас
вирушити в подорож на наших уроках ми будемо
говорити про подорожі та пригоди,
ви розширите свій словниковий запас, вивчаючи
різні фрази  і вирази, які ви
вивчатимете інфінітивну форму дієслова,
допоможете вашим навичкам писати неформальний
лист у форматі журналу, а також придбаєте
навички та стратегії, які допоможуть вам
на іспитах
сказати привіт, добре, і давайте зануримося у
світ подорожей моя улюблена тема
пристрасть  мого життя, і я не можу більше погодитися
зі словами рук Крістіана
Андерсена подорожувати – це жити, що
ти про це думаєш, як би ти завершив
цю фразу, що подорожує для тебе,
візьми ручку та джату та
запиши свою  Завершення фрази start
with to travel is go on буде посилатися на
фрази пізніше на наших уроках, готові
отримати, тож давайте приступимо до справи, коли
ви почуєте слово travel, яке є
словами, які виникають у вас  Подумайте про
них і протягом 30 секунд запишіть
усі слова, які ви можете згадати на
тему подорожі,
готові, добре, подивіться на цю хмару слів,
знайдіть слова, які ви записали,
і без гучних інших слів, які ви знаєте
[Музика]
готово, я не можу, але особняк ще
одне слово, це дійсно важливо
використовувати, говорячи про подорожі,
подивіться на це один останній останній
повторіть це слово один останній добре,
що викликає сильне бажання
блукати, щоб подорожувати  і досліджувати
світ, скажімо, що це означає ще один останній
раз диво останні ворота давайте подумаємо про
український еквівалент цього слова, яке
ми маємо в нашій мові
джихад Росія, що є англійською, це
дивно, останній, давайте поглянемо на
речення, щоб побачити, як воно використовується,
тож давайте читаємо разом. Остання зима в Меріленді
надихнула її на написання подорожей,
скажімо, що вона могла б поділитися своїми подорожами з
іншими, або через те, що я дивувався, що втратив,
мій паспорт був застряг у 40
різних країнах або  Хоча Гаррі
одружений, він
не може змиритися з ним, тому що його
жага подорожей змушує його літати з країни
в країну, скажи, як сказати це англійською:
raha de poder a pretrested Pedroza wat
англійською
, це бажання подорожувати.
опитування, час відпусток,
перед цим ви дасте відповідь на шість запитань, будь ласка,
намалюйте таблицю з трьома стовпцями і шістьма
рядками. Приготуйте сковороду, вам потрібно
спочатку відповісти на запитання про себе та
заповнити перший стовпець, я зачитаю
запитання  голосно
готовий до роботи питання номер один як
ви зазвичай подорожуєте під час відпустки
варіант a на машині B на поїзді C на літаку
пишіть лише літери a B або C питання
номер два чому ви зазвичай їдете на
відпочинок,
привіт, відвідати друзів та родину  B до
міста чи курорту у вашій країні побачити
місто чи курорт за кордоном
питання номер три, який тип
Говарда ви зазвичай берете активний
відпочинок чи пляжний відпочинок подивіться вихід на
екскурсію номер чотири
w  ти любиш робити у відпустці
відвідувати галереї музеї та
археологічні пам'ятки бути у формі
та робити якісь вправи C просто розслаблятися та розслаблятися
номер п'ять, де ти зупинишся на відпустці
привіт, у гостьовому будинку в готелі, будь у
родича друзів вдома C на  кемпінг
і останнє, що найкраще
у відпустці,
відволіктися від рутини,
знайомитися з новими місцями, дивитися зустрічатися
з друзями, отримати чи заповнили ви
першу колонку своїми власними відповідями,
тепер ви збираєтеся слухати мм  а
жінка, яка відповідає на ті самі запитання, що й зараз
у таблиці, послухайте й заповніть
наступні дві колонки, готові,
ми не дуже організовані, і ми
зазвичай робимо все в
останню хвилину, моя дружина ненавидить літати, тому це
означає, що ми не літаємо  будь-де літаком, нашим
улюбленим напрямком є Франція, і ми за
вичай їдемо потягом, ми їдемо на Eurostar, як
й йде під каналом, це ві
мінний сервіс, швидкий і комфортний, то
і ми просто подорожуємо  у різних
містах, дивлячись на визначні місця, нам
дуже подобається культурна діяльність, тому
ми будемо ходити на художні виставки,
прогулюватися історичними будівлями, такі
речі, які ми зазвичай зупиняємося в невеликих
сімейних готелях, нічого великого та
розкішного, що мені найбільше подобається у
відпустках  бачити місця, в яких я ніколи раніше не
був, і дійсно маю час, щоб
їх оглянути, я думаю, я просто люблю це,
я дуже чекаю на це добре, я люблю
робити все легко, зараз я
працюю зі своєю сестрою, і я зазвичай їду
з собою  пара друзів, у нас не так
багато грошей, але якщо ви забронювали
заздалегідь, ви можете отримати дуже дешеві
авіаквитки, ми часто їздимо до Італії, ми любимо
приморські місця та пляжі, і ми
часто зупиняємося в кемпінгу, є деякі
Ви можете піти туди, де для вас розставлені намети,
є відповідні ліжка і навіть
холодильник, це дійсно розкішно,
ми не дуже багато робимо, я просто люблю бути
поза офісом і на свіжому повітрі,
купатися і засмагати добре,
готуйтеся, давайте  перевірити а  відповіді,
це відповіді відповідей чоловіка, а
ось жіночі, чи є у вас те саме,
ми збираємося порівняти власні відповіді
з відповідями доповідача, як
зустрічатися, давайте подивимося, наприклад, моя
особиста відповідь на перше запитання:
див.  Питання стосувалося того, яким
транспортом ви віддаєте перевагу подорожувати, це
стосується літака, тому ми обоє, і я, і
чіп віддаємо перевагу подорожам літаком,
це найшвидший вид транспорту, і
вам потрібно кілька годин, щоб
повністю змінити обстановку, зараз це
ваша черга подивіться на свої відповіді
та порівняйте їх з доповідачами, знайдіть,
що у вас з ними спільного, і
розкажіть про це, використовуйте фрази ми обидва
носимо спікер 2, а я також
люблю робити щось готове, добре
ось питання та  ваші відповіді зроби це
[Музика]
добре попрацював,
тепер давайте обговоримо подивіться на
запитання подумайте про свої відповіді, що під
номером один
, краще забронювати важче в останню
хвилину чи завчасно
навіщо відповісти на
запитання номер два, чи б ви віддали перевагу
відправитися в пакетний тур або подорожувати
самостійно, чому дістатися, і питання
номер 3 ви б краще зупинилися в
невеликому гостьовому будинку або розкішному
п'ятизірковому готелі та наводили б причини.
з вами одна дуже
корисна техніка, щоб покращити свої
навички розмови, навіть будучи вдома
без репетиторів, використовуйте свій смартфон
і додаток диктофон і запишіть
свою розмову, після чого послухайте її
і оцініть зосередженість на хороших фразах, які ви
використали, а також на помилках і подумайте
зі способів, як покращити його, говорити
ще раз і записувати себе, зробіть це стільки
разів, скільки необхідно, і ви побачите
результат, ваше мовлення, безумовно, буде
краще готове перевірити це перейти
до уроку, а тепер ми перейдемо далі,
скажімо  подивіться на слова в
полі тест вирішує, в яку
подорож ми збираємося прослухати текст
поїздом, машиною, літаком або диваном,
давайте разом прочитаємо слова, побачимо, що
встановлено відділ автобусної бригади  arture control паспорт
слово реєстрація конвеєр дата ремінь
закуски та безпека про який тип
травми йдеться готовий, безперечно,
мова йде про подорож на літаку, зараз
ось кілька фотографій, знайдіть слова
в полі, щоб назвати ці фотографії,
давайте перевіримо разом,
тому першим  малюнок це
інформаційна табло одна дошка відправлення
правильно скажімо разом, це слово
отримати зображення номер два, там є
місце, чому ви можете або покласти свій
багаж багажу, або взяти її багаж, так що
це конвеєрна стрічка скажи це
разом  стрічка конвеєра отримати наступну
це ваше формулювання автобус з ним слово
посадковий талон гарний наступний ви знаєте
це слово написати гарнітура скажи це ще раз
гарнітура
добре, хто ці люди
екіпаж ваша черга екіпаж комплект і останній
ви можете побачити їхню їжу  і напої одним
словом це освіжаючі закуски
давайте посидимо разом закуски
супер подивіться на завдання ось текст
з пропусками ваше завдання використовувати
слова  від коробки до заповнення пропусків,
чувак, запишіть цифри
від 1 до 14 і запишіть слова
з поля
[Музика]
добре готово, давайте перевіримо і перевіримо,
перш за все, здійснивши свій перший рейс
, не забудьте зібрати  ваш квиток і
ваш паспорт у вашій ручній поклажі, коли
ви прибудете до стійки реєстрації, ваші
сумки будуть зважені та поставлені на
стрічку конвеєра, вам видадуть
посадковий талон, виділять місце та скажуть
пройти до зали вильоту, щоб
туди дістатися  ви пройдете паспортний
контроль і перевірку безпеки, подивіться на
табло вильоту в залі, щоб ви
знали, до якого номера виходу вам потрібно підійти,
коли настав час сідати на борт, екіпаж
направить вас на ваше місце, коли ви
садитесь, і ви повинні пристебнутися  ваш
ремінь безпеки перед зльотом вам подадуть
напої, і більшість компаній
надають розважальну систему з гарнітурою,
тож коли ви можете злетіти та відвідати одне
з міст, подивіться на це
фото, де в світі він може бути
розташований  чи хотіли б ви відвідати це
місце, чому б ви там робили,
прочитайте текст, ігноруючи прогалини, і перевірте
свої прогнози
[Музика]
готово отримати так, де це місто розташоване добре,
вони роблять те, що називається, який фестиваль
там проводиться, знайдеться точно зима
фестиваль вогнів, а тепер давайте зосередимося на
реченнях з пробілами, які ми будемо робити з вами
навколо читання проміжків, тому подивіться
на перший проміжок, і
друзі запропонували мені піти сюди,
тому що це місце, в якому
має бути частина мови  this gap noun adjective
that which прикметник неодмінно знімає
цей прикметник бути позитивним або негативним,
якщо мої друзі рекомендували відвідати це
місце позитивна дитина подивіться на
три варіанти: соромно, захоплююче
та розчаровує, який із трьох
підходить тут.
або
розчаровує - туристична зона
, три, безумовно, захоплюючі, а тепер
зверніть увагу, що я написав у
пробілу у варіанті B  або саме
слово слово це хороша ідея, коли
ви виконуєте завдання на нутрощі правильно
ціле слово, а не букву варіанту
чи знаєте ви, чому ви будете використовувати його на
самому останньому етапі виконання цього завдання, ви
прочитаєте весь текст  не
вибираючи знову правильний варіант, тому, коли
ви виконуєте це завдання, напишіть слово в
проміжку праворуч, воно скаже, зараз ваша черга
читати аналізуйте та виберіть правильні
варіанти виконайте завдання
[Музика]
добре, давайте перевіримо разом,
тому спочатку ми  вже зробили, давайте
зосередимося на другому проміжку, ми зупинилися в
чомусь, що це може
бути варіанти: готельний курорт або каюта, так
каюта, що це, це невеликий
дерев'яний
будиночок, свого роду будиночок дядька Тома, його власний
мертвий кіт о, мамо  це бути тут слово
хатинка в торговому районі
зараз Курорт інший варіант Курорт
є місце, куди люди ходять
відпочивати спеціально, це може бути гірськолижний курорт
пляжний курорт відпочинковий курорт у нашому випадку
звучить не дуже добре, і яке точно
залишилося
готель м  можливо, ми перевіримо,
отримати третій, давайте подивимося хороша
можливість оглянути багато магазинів,
і у нас є три варіанти в захваті, це
означає, що ми, люди, можемо бути в захваті,
хто найкращий, тому що щось
трапилося, це про магазини, є
сумніви, що чудовий інший варіант, який  це
правда дверний прохід або захоплення, що є
дієприкметником теперішнього часу від слова насолода що
ви вибрали
добре номер чотири моя мама хм
застереження для нас що ми можемо зробити з
бронюваннями, ми можемо забронювати,
але якщо у мене є застереження, я маю це
для себе
або зарезервую  для когось або на
майбутнє, але ми не можемо забронювати це
неможливо тільки мати або зробити добре
вибрати правильний варіант гарний номер п'ять ми
були в захваті від цього, так що, на щастя,
насправді це пощастило для нас або
раптом ми цього не очікували в  все або
природно, звичайно, ми були щасливі
добре вибрати правильний один номер
шість фестиваль, який
проводив те, що відбувалося з moobot ISA
потрібен час доторкнутися до t  він розгалужується або бере
участь, щоб взяти участь brad Interest, так
що з трьох ми можемо поставити після
слова take, говорячи про
фестиваль, добре, сьомий наш останній
день
ага, це про прийменники, які ми використовуємо,
говорячи про час у або на або при
розмові про  точний час, який ми використовуємо, коли
ми говоримо про дні, дати, які ми використовуємо,
і говоримо про місяці рік століття, які ми
використовуємо, виберіть правильний, і
останній це був ідеальний кінець
чудової подорожі чи
подорожі, що ви про це думаєте  ми
дізнаємося всі ці слова трохи пізніше, а
тепер давайте перевіримо відповіді, скажімо, давайте
прочитаємо весь текст на вихідних у
Рейк'явіку минулих вихідних ми з сестрою
поїхали в Рейк'явік в Ісландії друзі, які
там були, запропонували мені
поїхати, тому що це так  захоплююче місце для
відвідування, ми зупинилися в чудовому готелі, розташованому
в головному торговому районі, це дало
нам хорошу можливість оглянути
безліч чудових магазинів, які моя мама
забронювала для нас у Blue La  Goon
і розкішний спа-центр у подарунок,
звичайно, ми були в захваті від цього,
а потім ми обидва почувалися фантастично, ми
також пішли на фестиваль зимових вогнів,
який проходив, коли ми
були там, фестиваль святкує
зиму та збільшення світлового дня
після тривалого періоду  у темряві в наш
останній день ми вирішили прогулятися
навколо озера Churning, яке є невеликим
озером у центрі міста, хоча воно було
вбито, небо було кришталево чистим і
світило сонце, це був ідеальний
кінець чудової подорожі.  як я
обіцяв, давайте подивимося на ці
три слова trip travel та tour
відповідають словам та їхнім визначенням,
давайте перевіримо, сер подорож для задоволення,
особливо як відпустка, відвідування кількох
різних місць у цьому районі, це
екскурсія загальна діяльність переїзду з
одного  місце до іншої подорожі та подорожі
це коротка подорож, щоб відвідати місце
та повернутися знову давайте попрактикуємося
ось речення, будь ласка, доповніть
кожне речення  з правильним словом
європейський тур десятьма містами, тому що ми відвідуємо
різні місця, це тур, робота
передбачає часті подорожі
незліченну кількість правильно часті подорожі ми
витрачаємо багато часу під час подорожей
через хорошу роботу наступний
з Лондона в Оксфорд  і назад -
це поїздка туди й назад, це
так, щоб зробити тур по Бельгії пішки в
турі, відвідавши різні місця Кейт
наступна шкільна поїздка туди й назад
і остання, як скоротити час у дорозі
знову незліченні й переважно  зосередьтеся на
часі, проведеному в дорозі, подивіться
на картинку це Рейк'явік місто, про яке ми
читаємо, подивіться на картинку і
дайте відповідь на питання, чи б ви хотіли
провести вихідні в Рейк'явіку,
що б ви там робили, запишіть себе,
відповідаючи на це питання добре  і
сьогодні ми вивчимо слова про
подорожі, ви можете потренуватися у вивченні
цих слів за допомогою Quizlet, скажімо, скористайтеся
зчитувачем QR-кодів, перейдіть на сторінку і
потренуйтеся вивчати ці слова, я сподіваюся, що це
буде чудово  допоможіть вам, щоб
подорож у тисячу миль
розпочалася з одного кроку, і сьогодні ми перейшли
до нової теми для домашнього
завдання спочатку вивчіть слова з
цього набору туристичних слів на Quizlet та
створіть туристичну рекламу
туру  вихідні в Рейк'явіку
дзвонить, наш урок закінчився, тому
дякую за участь і слідкуйте за оновленнями та
до скорої зустрічі
[Музика]
ви